i really have like a substitute
teacher's ass yeah you know you're that
sloppy joe ass
will you calm down okay i'm right here
dude and it's asian awareness
it's asian awareness month
back off my broccolini get your life
together
don't touch me bro i'm not touching you
dude
ah dog you guys need to get enough
family hot dogging contest
i bet you all got some origami hands
baby oh
damn i took one of his i started i'm not
kidding i took it
five minutes later like i was like what
the [ __ ] didn't like i didn't feel it
kick in because i was so used to my
prescription
10 minutes later the my teachers like
clapping her hands in front of my face
i was so focused on something on the
whiteboard i started to drool and i
zoned out that's how i
see that's the [ __ ] that sounds
effective man that's the focus i need
out of you
you should have got enough on a [ __ ]
f-16 and [ __ ] fought the terrorists
man
yeah that's what our [ __ ] army needs
man yeah
if you're that focused dog yeah
so what'd you do with your focus you
just kind of went to sleep i know i was
this was like when i was in school like
i did my uh like i
had school all day i had practice i was
like
what are you doing i mean you're just in
math class taking adderall and [ __ ] it's
the same
dude it's not like they changed the
numbers it's been around since when we
and you got cell phones these days i
don't do anything to eat
and you have chinese kids in your class
we weren't even allowed to have chinese
kids yeah it sounds like you're just
like
you just like to get high bubba you're a
drug addict
so is your father yeah you're a drug
addict dude
and brendan you're dressed like that uh
you're dressed like the the
that husband from that uh what's that
cartoon nick
a husband from that cartoon the
flintstones huh yeah
dude you look like weekends look like
dude you look like you're like a gay
you look like weekend at bernie's side
piece
just you look like head flint stone do
you look like a gay freaking
guy who lives in like you know what when
i put this i like the master man i look
like i frequent the abbey
pretty often you look like a concierge
yeah
i had a ball bag dude i look like i look
like the ice boy i'm looking at the
wheat
the abby man yeah see you running low on
eyes sweetie
sweetie so it's okay hey boys he looks
like the guy
like you go around the cart path but on
a bike you know
and pull over there's a little trolley
no i'm the guy at the abbey with the
shots i wrote my tits in your face
people like that now people like man's
tits and everything man we had nikki
glaziers in here and she didn't know
what she said uh
what did she say about sex nick i like
all of it i don't know she almost lost
us our raising cane spot
oh that's all right what would she say
she don't like chicken she don't like
mint she don't i mean she likes men she
likes men only certainly
sorry she don't like male chickens
basically i guess or she doesn't she
doesn't eat chicken she's vagin
oh she just eats the plants she's
veggies it's working though she bought
it up now
yeah oh yes she gets best buddy in
comedy celery mommy though oh yeah
there's not a lot of bodies in comedy
though are there
i like good bodies men or women
no it's not really it's not that it's
not that sport it's not
it's not it's not you know it's just
that's one thing you got to really
you're gonna have to uh oh you're right
i'm at a crossroads right now because i
was in the gym this morning
deadlift in 475 and they go you want to
post this i said i don't think so man
yeah it is a thick boy summer but i
don't think so also blew my tricep out
so that's good
it is hanging on by thread right now
really you were you were at the comedy
store last night
yeah are you dressed like that oh yeah
they won't let you in
we've got a flaunt my aunt uh we've had
some good ones recently we're gonna try
to do one a week and this guy
returns and he's awesome he said [ __ ]
your comedy store i met this guy before
no i appreciate it nick thank you for
keeping the show rolling
neothon schwendenbrob is that 10 speed
splitter back with another hitter boy
travis from majority ohio nothing good
ever came from here nothing good comes
from here like
my aunt bert as you can see there's
obviously a little bit of inner family
erotica going on
somewhere on my mother's side because
that's where this woman came from let's
see she loves bingo
she loves the color blue she's always
got her signature blue eyeshadow on
100 percent of the time since i was a
kid bingo
from michigan she always says
she loves bingo and she loves talking to
my grandma for hours and hours and hours
at a time
oh yeah she actually had to wait for my
grandfather to die
before she was allowed back in the house
he hated her so
much oh yeah anyway here's bert she's
80.
dang she'll raise nick i bet hell yeah
she'll take nick
under the wing nick has a new couch to
crash off yeah mom
doug she uh n11 you think that's a wig
or what
i do believe that's a wig no nick nick
how do you do nick you know old ladies
you think it's a wig
i i do know old lady i was just visiting
in denver
my great-aunt donna who has alzheimer's
and her whole life she wore a bouffant
wig it looked like we called it
the beehive when i was growing up and we
saw our entire repertoire of wigs no way
that's a wig
oh yeah my grandma was just like going
through them nostalgic like oh she wore
this one
you should have put some on dog and took
pictures thanksgiving freaking head
piece right yeah man
oh wow and so this lady now one thing i
do i want to say this first of all
this this lady's 80 years old eight zero
years
looks good for 80 man wow
and she's running 12 bingo cards so
still with it so
trying to make that bank dog yeah and i
bet she's doing it without adderall
i want to say that you think to somebody
because i was going to say i'm smelling
a little bit of adderall on granny here
yeah granny's snorting that adderall no
one plays bingo that long in that many
cards without doing some adderall
but she has blue maybe she's been beaten
by her ex-husband but what happened to
her eyes or she has is that eye shadow
that's her signature look he said it
does look like she got slapped around a
little bit maybe her husband you know
older gentleman back in the 50s
yeah if you're not listening you get
slapped in the face back in those early
ufc days yeah
like the good fellow wives yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
i love her man birdo is her name bert
yeah
which is interesting i think you get so
old as a woman some of you just take on
a man's name
thank god she doesn't have her shirt off
bert
yeah i would like to see nick
she's 80. yeah well she's beautiful man
i appreciate you sending her in and i
definitely think yeah let's set her up
with stevie weeby
that's what i was gonna say we found a
date with stevie weeby man
like we finally found this let's set
this up you send me pictures or like
dude
i don't wanna see this [ __ ] man send me
that big black ass
with the the oil in it i'm like bro you
need a friend dog
dude you [ __ ] what
you look unbelievable today i do
look at you ben look at you you look
like an
11 year old french boy on hg8
that's italian okay dude the other
french the one that starts with an f
here's a guy right here under a bridge
what's up theo what's up big boy i'm the
real fan
thick boy and the rest of the cat's fam
it's jacob tapping in from santa cruz
california
and i got a king of stinger for you all
natural hot springs
you soaking in that warm earth hitter
let me know what you think
king it or sing it me personally
i'm taking a dip in these cold west
coast waters baby
that's great different dog gang gang
buzz buzz some fat seals gang bait shout
out san jose man
shout out a lot of missing people up in
that area
um hot springs hot springs are like
they're
it's cool at first but in the middle of
summer that [ __ ] is still hot man
it's like everybody pissing the pool you
feel me and i'll pee in that hot spring
nobody knows what's going on yeah yeah
yeah warm's warm
yeah i think you can i think it's okay
to pee in hot springs i think it's okay
to pee anywhere but
i think that what does this guy want to
ask us do we like natural hot springs
bro you gotta respect it because that's
mother nature's outlet you know what i'm
saying that's basically you don't need a
pool guy
uh-uh that's that menstrual cycle of
freaking mama nature bro and you gotta
respect it you know
she's busting out she's been either
working out of the gym or something
she's got a sweat she's gotta let it out
mother nature's warm snot yeah yeah
you got to enjoy that yeah i love it man
so i think it's just too warm though
well for a long time i think you can
handle it brendan yeah you're probably
right
should we see what some people on
hollywood boulevard thought about hot
springs yeah let's go one more time to
this freaking
thing natural hot springs
natural hot springs king it yeah why not
right why why nature nature yeah you
have to say nature right
natural hot springs i can't understand
it
hold on here you pause it go back we'll
come back to that one
what go back now and just show it just
show it yeah
look how uh heavy the microphone is when
he holds
is one word right nature natural hot
springs
awesome okay why because the nature no
you always see titties
it's like a guarantee you know what
thank you for your goddamn honesty
she said it you're the first one to say
that shut this down man one more time
thank you for your goddamn mom i know
and then he goes and culturally
culturally appropriates that sex toy he
got a black sex toy
yeah and he keeps sending it to me i'm
like stevie send it somebody else man
did he knew it my girl saw this man she
was like what the hell is that i said
that's my friend and it's a nick what is
it i don't want to
i don't want to get him in trouble man
really well i mean you guys decide
i just you know i i love stevie and i
know he's been on such a journey
being bobby's brother and whatever
happened to them but
uh i just did i didn't know what was
going on last time he's in here he's
just so
sex depraved you know it well it sounds
like he he has a real
uh fetish and he well here it is it's
disgusting um he has real fetish and
he's also addicted to
sexual [ __ ] you know yeah he's a real
problem
i feel like we're kind of helping them
out though oh i don't feel like we're
getting them on the right track
i don't feel that then he sent me that
picture oh you got off the track
what'd i tell you nick dude i was me and
my girl watching our [ __ ] tv
show and i see my phone go off i pull it
pops up
and look here's the saddest thing is is
he has a sandal on under it
that hold on he still has the tags on
him he's going to return him
so here's what i want to know is that a
tag or is that a condom
that's a tag bro that's a tag and the
sad thing and this is the kind of stuff
that i don't like about the present
economy is
the type of people that buy sandals
masturbate in them and then return them
you think that's what tibia wanted out
of this man you think it was like vans
or adidas wanted out of this
are you getting that fake black ass and
nutting and this is cultural
appropriation isn't it
it's a nice ass though what
i'm just saying i mean i'm trying to
shoot some positive notes here
not doing anything man take it down nick
jesus christ that's a lot
dude why don't you do a mold of your ass
and start selling it on [ __ ] theo
no nothing would make bank bro
would it yeah yeah
no spitballing ideas here man i know you
are it's like that shark tank segment we
got
you think we could i know who's going to
buy it i think people will buy more
maybe
be surprised one of your leg lamps like
if they did a burning shot
cool i think i could see the people
doing that
look i have different habits you know
and i want to feel good so those are a
couple things
and uh some things i do to feel good or
i have a lot of lettuce i have a lot of
spinach in the evening
i'll have a couple of red bell peppers
baby i'll do that for myself
and i stay hydrated and by that i mean
liquid iv sometimes you don't have a bag
you can just put in your arm and you
don't have a needle
to vein out so you gotta use liquid iv
first thing in the morning before a
workout when you feel run down hangover
cure
etc it's great tasting it's functional
product
makes you feel great literally it feels
like you're drinking three glasses of
water in one
it really does yep the hydration
multiplier plus
immune support is cutting edge
blend of vitamin c zinc and well mune
in convenient single serving packets
they've got it for you liquid iv
can provide two to three times more
hydration than water alone
with every purchase look what i'd be
doing it's a serving of liquid iv
to someone in need and that's probably
someone that's thirsty
get your liquid ivs hydration multiplier
plus
immune support in bulk at costco
or order online and get 25 off when you
go to
liquid iv.com and use code
kats at checkout that's 25 off
anything you order when you get better
hydration today using promo code cats
at liquidive.com get hydrated
good to see you today it's playoff time
you know it big stakes
bigger promotions it's time to hammer
the over and score some cash draft kings
sportsbook
is giving you a chance to lower the over
under
on a featured playoff game that's right
all players who place a bet on the
featured basketball game will have a
hand
in lowering the over under on the game
that's right for every
every 1500 players who bet the over on
the select game
the over under will drop by one point
that's right download the top-rated
draftking sportsbook app
now and use promo code k-a-t-s
when you sign up to hammer the over
hammer the over for every 1500 people
that bet on the
bet the over in the feature game the
line will decrease by one point yes
this is your chance to improve the odds
of the overheating so tell your friends
and family
this is a team effort hammer the over
and improve your odds of doubling your
money that's promo code cats
kats for a limited time only on
draftkings sportsbook
must be 21 or older new jersey
indianapolis are pa
only restrictions apply maximum 25
wager one per customer offerings five
twenty three twenty one see
draftkings.com sportsbook for details
gambling problem call one eight hundred
gambler
or in indiana 1-809 with it
uh this guy's got a king in her stinger
for us what's up fellas this is ty
coming at you from sonoma county
california that wine country
got a king or stinger for you taxidermy
oh yeah
talking about those flying [ __ ]
hitters and throwing them on the wall
yeah bang bang stuff stuff
now that's the real dark arts i don't
trust people to have dead animals on
their wall that's rule number one of
living club you feel me like if i go
into a house and they got dead animals
all over the wall
you got problems really yeah man have
you been to joe rogan's house
i can imagine he has dead animals dead
comedians
he probably has tony hinchcliffe
and drones why don't they make the geese
put it back in the air
and it can do a button where it can poop
yeah put some helmets on those [ __ ]
so people don't know it's drones we fly
over into russia or north korea
china what's up dude these are some
stone cold american geese dropping bombs
daddy
now let's go to chin on this chin how
long is a goose going to last in china
just kind of
just milling around who's going to last
yeah that's a good point before it's
rotisserie
if it looks like an actual goose yeah
man probably
probably a day yeah yeah by the way i
did taxidermy once
i tried really yeah you tried doing it
for a job
no i caught a large mouth bass when i
was a kid
and the fishing magazines would have
taxidermy kits in the back of it so i
ordered it no
froze the bass that's just good and i
tried to do it myself and it was a
disaster yeah take it easy jeffrey
dahmer now why was it a disaster though
brendan don't be so mean to him yeah
you're right why was it a disaster you
just
started thawing out and just like
breaking apart in pieces
would you freeze it in formaldehyde no
just a regular freezer did they tell you
what to do before
i read all the instructions and it was
just a disaster
but do you think that there just wasn't
enough instruction do you think that you
weren't prepared that day
it was a fish probably a little harder
to you know fish for sure because it's
not going to stay together well
and i wasted the entire fish i could
have eaten it bro now think if
not look now first of all that goes
right back to my first question
how long would it burn as i'm saying
now chin now think about if you have to
do that whole process with like a
big-ass grizzly bear 800 pound beer yeah
not doing it
but a bird i think will be pretty easy a
bird would be easy yeah but think you
think about like a [ __ ] tiger
or you know people have those bears on
the wall you gotta take out all the
organs drinking blood yeah nightmare
yeah team effort
i just call cam haynes what's up daddy
take care of this thing
it makes you know it's on your phone oh
yeah yeah you thought about trying it
again
no after that first i was just
devastated god i wish you would do it
again and film it for us chin
put on your [ __ ] nose stinking oh
this is terrible you try it with a
squirrel
yeah no did y'all talk about hinchcliffe
on you guys a show on tfa tkz
yeah did you no we uh we didn't talk
about it yesterday we didn't know about
it yesterday i don't think or yeah i
don't know when it happened
no just where were you at on it i mean i
just there shouldn't be cell phones
recording anybody's
first of all i just don't know that's a
safe place and then
the problem too is i talked to comics
who
tour with derrick i'm sorry i talked
with comics who tour with tony
and some other guys who were there and
they're like dude he's been
he's been doing that that set like
that's that's part of his set
for weeks man it crushes yeah and
someone decides to cut it so
if you just see that yeah it looks
terrible he's like but if you see the
whole thing
it's really good yeah if you don't like
i'll admit like when you first see like
jesus christ tony
but also you're supposed to be in a safe
zone comedy zone i know a lot of guys
they start recording sets like that and
blasting out people can get in trouble
man
that's not what they are yeah i'm sure
if you took some of my lines and just
put them out there random like that like
yeah if it was real blunt you don't know
the context and you just put oh
theo said this but you're not in a
comedy venue or anything like that like
that's not
that's not the right thing to do yeah
and also that comic who did it to him
you know he's opened up for him a number
of times also posted how thankfully it
was for tony it's like
depending how he feels you know and
again this is me going based off tony
has done this previously so you knew he
was going to do this and then now you do
it
and put hashtag you know asian pride
week or whatever
uh he's seen clout chase yeah this i
tweeted yesterday snitch clout comedy is
a new thing apparently
and i don't know if i really i just felt
like it just felt
like look man we've all people say
things it's wrong sometimes
or it's right to you or whatever i think
you take it up with that person
tony's also remember this tony's a
roaster he's a roaster like he said some
horrible [ __ ] to me like it's just it's
if you ever seen kill tony like he
lights people up dude oh if you've ever
seen the first 60 episodes of this show
i've said some horrible [ __ ] to you
yeah but it's like uh i'm not going to
record him like look at field believe me
yeah you are nick is anyway
nick might get chapter but no i you know
i just felt like
i just don't like the way i wish i just
don't like the route we're going i wish
it had a different
i wish there were some different punch
lines in it for sure that would like at
least like kind of
seem like it made it more entertaining
but then i think that's
that's the point i think if it would
have been more funny
that you know he would get more backing
online but when you just see that clip
even i
like i saw it ashley was like it was
terrible yeah what's your stance on it
chin
as an asian american i just thought it
wasn't funny so if it was funny
it'd probably be different right i agree
and i'm not i'm not
i'm not gonna say that tony's the
funniest guy in the world to me right
but i will say that his thing is saying
abusive and
messed up [ __ ] is being mean dude a lot
of times that's in some of the same vain
as hari shafir in some of that world you
know
actually it's they're different but but
uh no you're on the right path like it's
that
it's that it's that type of comedy like
tony is a savage
and like he go you know he goes below
the belt that's just what he does
right and sometimes when you're saying
me like messed up [ __ ] it's not
it's there's no plan for it it's also
not for everybody like that wasn't
supposed to be blasted to the masses
like that's his
tight-knit group yeah so i just felt
like yeah it just felt like kind of
clout chasey a little bit to me at the
end no it's no different those girls on
raya posting with the celebrities like
they're not doing that because they're
upset that [ __ ] ben affleck
dm'd them they're they're just trying to
get clout well that's what this comment
is
i don't know well i don't know maybe
tony had been rude also to the guy i
wonder if there was something else that
happened that made him
feel yeah to do this like maybe he was
doing and maybe he said something
again i have no [ __ ] clue so i'm
talking my ass there but maybe he was
like hey man
i don't like that that hurts my feelings
please don't do that again tony was like
what went on stage it again he's like
all right dude i told you
yeah so maybe there's that but even that
just as a comic like
there's code man you don't snitch on
each other and now tony's lost
his representation he can't perform
there anymore
where he does kill tony the venue won't
let him allow them anymore so
there's repercussions these days yeah i
haven't heard
the opener talk was it a good impression
i don't
know i'm just kidding i'm just kidding
that's a good question oh i don't even
know
uh nick ogle he's one of our favorite
submitters he's got another king at her
sting it for us
what up brandon what up theo coach
corner nick chen
got a king at her sting it for you
sitting here at the car hop here it is
pet control
some of these girls don't have on their
roller blades
so i was gonna see what you guys thought
about it king of her sting it
your car hops with some roller blades
buzz buzz gang buzz baby i'll tell you
the sonic sonic is a real
one thing i'm noticing even being more
in the central east a lot of times these
days sonic is a
staple brendan it's the suez canal of of
feeding
it's really people like to go there and
get fed they like to see the food
brought on out to them on wheels
yeah you know you'll see somebody
videoing you know they'll get their kid
out there and have them video you know
the guy wheel up to him and video you
know
get him a smoothie those girls are
talented too because they gotta they
gotta balance the smoothies they're on
skates
yeah they're all skilled the craziest
part is it was one girl was pregnant and
on skates
i wouldn't risk your child's mental
health did did you did you roller skate
growing up
oh yeah oh there's a place called skate
city oh
all the girls there you make sure you
went far grabbed the wall it's like you
going around like i'm posted up girl
yeah i'm cool i'm just going to stay
here you go around one more time
the white nfl dude roller skating hell
yeah [ __ ] was clean bro
then black people got involved and took
that [ __ ] over dancing to [ __ ]
doing all cool flips and shows yeah i'm
just going to post up yeah
the best we could do is go under
somebody's legs every now and then yeah
i'd spread my i'd go backwards
if you went backwards i felt like
[ __ ] you did that that otter oh yeah
oh wow [ __ ] david blaine going
backwards yeah that's nice dude
yeah jim we didn't get your thoughts off
i feel bad i cut you off up there
on the giant on the uh asian comedian
thing yeah it wasn't
it just didn't feel funny yeah i told
brandon until i was like it just wasn't
funny yeah
if it was funny it'd be different it was
like easy jokes like soy sauce like what
the hell yeah
what do you what do you think should
happen to him chin yeah i think everyone
deserves a chance
would you say everyone deserves a chance
he [ __ ] up you saying a second chance
yeah
what do you think about the guy filming
him and putting it outside that's what i
told brandon too i was like that's the
thing i thought was the worst
that guy filming like leave that in
there and plus tony might be working out
the joke
we don't know so right yeah they said i
talked to other comedians down there in
austin like dude he's been doing it
before
and he's crashing with it he's like
trying to figure it out
but also some there's people there's
there's there's there's
there's all types of entertainment so
it's like some entertainment
is crass messed up stuff pornography
compared to ballet you know they're both
like
uses of the body to do things and one of
them is extremely vulgar and messed up
and one of them
is more artistic to some but other
people see it here but here's the thing
like if i'm into that type of whatever
ballet i'll watch it if i don't like
that porn i don't have to watch it you
don't have to buy tickets to watch 20
inch clip right you can do where the
[ __ ] he wants
yeah maybe it's not for you but to lose
gigs over it
because he has a fan base some people
dig it
yeah debate club porn or ballet
i'm gonna go ballet these days man i
can't take any more corn
ballet is so boring uh this is the
easiest king or sing it we've ever had
porn man really oh yeah man i like my
colleagues
black swan best of both worlds yeah
black swan have you seen black fish dude
with how they treated blackfish i know
man unbelievable man it's basically the
amistad underwater this lady makes bad
decisions let's see what she has to say
hey guys lindsay from ct here heard
you're giving some relationship advice
so i'd love to hear your thoughts
back in march i started a job um
and like an idiot started [ __ ]
somebody at work
um i do have to preface that on the head
so you know it's pretty bad
you gotta hear that part okay sorry no
it's all good um i do have to preface
that i'm the head of hr so you know it's
pretty bad where
after the first night you have to sift
through the employee book when he leaves
your house [ __ ] my life
anyways uh no one at work knows and ever
since then we started to build a
relationship
and i know that at the end of the day
it's probably a bad move but you know
your heart wants what your heart
wants so we're trying to figure out
whether or not we tell people
you can stop which we obviously don't
want to do you don't have to put them
in your work relationships gang gang
buzz buzz
so what's her advice saying that she
found love but she's pregnant lose her
job i know she's gonna lose your job
yeah there's no love here man it's just
a good dick girl
yeah you're probably gonna lose your job
because we're all gonna see this now so
it's out of the bag
i don't know brandon looks like the ceo
at [ __ ] ratatouille's restaurant
today
that dude okay dude
look like a bouncer at a [ __ ]
lesbian french orphanage
you know it's that black swan got in my
throat
yeah so what's this lady's problem or
husband left uh she should she keep it
going with the guy that she's [ __ ]
work as the head of hr she's obviously
going to i mean
yeah this one's a slam dunk you're not
gonna take advice from us
stop sucking this guy off at the [ __ ]
water cooler yeah
look lady the water cooler is for
drinking
water and that's it young lady yeah
you're having a little too much cooler
over there um
i think look i think obviously if you
are a woman people are going to want to
have sex with your weather they know
you're not
and i think that this lady you know if
she
i think times have just changed you know
this is the kind of stuff that happened
to
women 50 years ago when they were the
the head of hr
would bang him out and then lose his job
and then drive off to a different city
and that's who this little social media
that's who this little motorcycle mama
is
you know oh it's jake paul
what up brandon what up theo love the
podcast love you guys
wanna ask you some relationship advice
pets in the bedroom what do you guys
think about that
i got two bubbas come here bubbas
you got there they love to lay in bed at
night
but it kind of gets in the way of that
boom boom room gang gang
so let me know what you guys think pets
in the bed
or are you kicking them out can't get
away from these guys man that's tough
especially when you got a big dog my
brother has a big dog his name is ruffy
and he's about 160 pounds
nothing sleeps between them that's a
full grown man sleeping between you
do you hate each other what's going on
there man if that dog's in the bed
yeah of course you i mean you can't have
your wiener schnitzel watching while you
bang out your girl you know what i'm
saying
you know i think there's something
almost so you've been smoking
cigarettes huh you've been smoking
cigarettes no i drove here
my hairdryer broke so i drove through
with my head out of the window oh that
makes sense
and uh a lot of the air hit my throat
man um
i think there's something about i dated
a girl one time who would put these you
know those blind those
light blocking things on that people
wear so the sun doesn't see their eyes
when they're trying to rest oh yeah
that's the sleep mask she would put
those on her dogs
if we were gonna be intimate oh wow so
she knew it was going down if she said
all right let me get the
the blue blockers out yeah yeah there's
blue blockers on these pups
but this is unbelievably jake paul
yeah this guy should definitely this guy
start calling out dylan
yeah this guy should definitely start
get on cameo fake jake paul i think
that'd be great
great dude we should have him call in
next week cut a promo cut a cameo that's
smart dude i would love to do that man
we'll buy your uh
we'll buy your hounds some nice treats
man if you'll do that for us um
but yeah i think if also i remember one
time
oh after kobe bryant had had the sex
accusations against him oh a long time
ago
there was a girl whose house i stayed at
in philadel
not philadelphia um somewhere somewhere
kind of scary but awesome is it related
to kobe bryant
yeah she used to wonder she had a great
dane
in her bed it was a full
bed right some nuts on him oh bro he you
could
one of his nuts i think i kind of rolled
over in the middle of the night yeah but
i rolled over you mean touched
hey look man it touched me man it rolled
down the bed onto me keep touching me
bro
yeah stop touching me but
that dog slept in between us dude and he
had just had those sex accusations
and i was like this lady's a wild cat
wild man
i don't know what kobe bryant's doing
that great dane and his nuts
but those great day nuts are unreal yeah
they get them brian callum nuts on them
dude let's see a picture
is that them that's not a great dane
actually i don't think that's a
is it oh yeah that is that's great she's
nuts oh yeah
and one of them looks like it's a girl
bigger than both of mine
it looks like a brain with cte dude yeah
those
look like those look like something a
kid would pick up during an easter egg
hunt
and look for a hundred dollars in it
don't look at that bug right there what
a
shiny two man no down left right there
oh this dog is a freak huh
another freaking leak that looks like a
stevie weeby toy
yeah oh don't let stevie get a hold of a
dog
uh but i i think people should know that
uh
db's like 50 so age-appropriate i'm just
saying
it like i don't think people know he's
50. he's pretty old i don't i don't know
exactly how old no he's not fit he's the
younger brother of bobby bobby's how old
55 you can't never tell they yeah
it's like you know just one day they
wake up and they look old as [ __ ]
yeah before that they're like 21.
bobby's 49 it says on
online so stevie weeby has to be at
least
45 46 yeah
wow i mean chin looks like the youngest
in here yeah
nick looks like billy bob thornton
that's not a big deal yeah that's true
huh yeah it's spot-on
i'll take that bad santa over there
billy throbs snort
sorry [ __ ] it's uh chin now can you
tell how old other asians are when you
guys get around each other is there kind
of a thing where you can just kind of
smell the time on each other
no cause i i thought stevie was younger
than me wow stevie looks young
i thought stevie especially the way you
know he's talking about playing video
games all the time losing his girlfriend
i thought he was like 31 yeah he looks
like in his 30s
um and he's small too yeah he dresses
delicate he's very delicate but i think
also damaged
and i think what happened was i mean we
got to complain about the crying
japanese woman outside that's not
something you they didn't say hey hottie
outside you know having a
tough time that wasn't the on the
comment sheet it was crying
she was crying because she couldn't get
in yeah and a woman is like
40 plus they don't yeah you know it's la
so they'll label anything a child here
you know what i'm saying so they can
still have sex with it
this will transition us into debate club
it's a little bit of a transition who's
this dumb
looks like nato american yeah yeah
dude hey theo hey brennan nick chen
shout out to the culture corner
holly here from knoxville you guys
should come out here and do some shows
i'm trying to see you live
i am but um anyways i have a dip club
for you
so um sharing a bedroom with your
significant other
or having your own separate bedroom so
when me and my boyfriend first moved in
together
he wanted separate bedrooms i didn't i
thought it was nuts didn't make sense to
me cut so many fights
but here we are three years later and i
absolutely love it
wouldn't go back any other way um
nothing of mine goes in his bedroom
nothing of his goes in mine completely
separate bedrooms
sleep together every night but we each
get our own space get to do what we want
with it
um get to keep it as messy as we want so
i absolutely love it
and i was just curious what you guys
think um
gang gang buzz buzz he's going that room
and farting that's like that right now
do you think bubba yeah he's letting it
rip dog oh really his own room getting
away from his girl
probably holding it in all [ __ ]
during [ __ ] narcos or some [ __ ] eight
series deep pulling that fart in
gets in his own room that blaster dog
being being a real man like that yeah i
think real men
fart the other thing is is though dude a
lot of young guys aren't even farting
anymore
the other day they're worried they're
gonna get canceled yeah yeah it came
fart
because they they're worried that some
of the farts will sound like a racial
slur
you know you're right dog the thing is
if if dude if you if you got a separate
room from stephanie and other
you're not gonna make it yeah you can't
even sleep with the
the person you love that's not good your
roommates yeah get a roommate you know i
love it
i love it i love this girl where she's
from holly from knoxville
how far is knoxville from you uh from
nashville it's about three hours i think
no no
might only be an hour and a half not
close might be announced closer might be
closer never been in knoxville could be
20 minutes wait i don't know
man i do not know uh
but i will tell you this man chin seems
like the type of dude that sleeps in a
separate room from his girl
yes i have to sleep with her what yeah i
feel comfortable
wow but you guys she has to sleep around
you guys don't even live together right
no we don't it doesn't count
i mean we stayed together for like weeks
before
yeah yeah but you can always dip back to
her own crib yeah she's
they're locked in that room together and
there's only one bad different story dog
no we like being together
well you guys should live together then
oh you know brendan looks like one of
those venice canal guys
oh on the boat yeah do that anymore
what no
way crime rate's too high in venice now
doggie is it
wow it's up like 120
well i think yeah that last clip man
yeah there you go
i might just be at the bellagio i've
seen that [ __ ] in the bellagio
that's a weird game what is that person
called do you know nick a gondolier
nice yeah gundler or gay
or a gay man a lot of these men it's
just people that couldn't
it's fellas that couldn't get a job at
disney world i think let's be honest
former mimes yeah yep a lot of
recovering moms dreamers to be mickey
mouse
i just [ __ ] do that all day the real
bummers the ones you see it like the
venetian and [ __ ]
oh yeah you know they want to be in the
real italy man i know you in vegas
oh but then they don't have to travel
that far either
yeah they're probably kind of nice to be
able to sleep in their own bed at night
what was that last one yeah what was the
last one we're talking about now what
about sleeping
if you hear though if you hear [ __ ]
like
like what's the name was saying it does
that sound like a is it just like the n
word is that the same thing or no
i mean so [ __ ] is for chinese right
right so it doesn't really affect me
that much to be
honest i think the n-word's like the
end-all be-all
it's worse and i'm gonna get a lot of
hate for that i'm sure
no i don't know if you i mean i i'm just
asking i have no idea
asians asians get upset at that dude we
have no
i would i want to go out on a limb and
say we have absolutely two or four
chinese fans you know
and i don't mean that in a bad way yeah
they don't first of all
you're not allowed to even broadcast
this in china they don't have wi-fi yeah
so
they have it i don't think they allow
them to have it
they control everything well they have
whatsapp i mean everything there is like
over
tick-tock it's a lot different internet
speeds are faster than anywhere in the
world
yeah mm-hmm oh no they don't you've got
to use vpn there but like it's hella
illegal
so you weren't that offended chin no i
thought i was just
i was little it was like super lean
[ __ ] and soy sauce was like that was
tough
yeah it was tough to see yeah it wasn't
funny yeah that's fine
that's the number one problem i think
yeah it was funny you'd been all right
but
some people are in seoul comics they had
that dog on tv for 20 years his name was
the insult comic
and he was afraid to sign it so was he
even that good at his job
cancer robert schmiegel yeah was that
who the owner was
yeah that was no rob schmiegel's a beast
man is he super beast
i don't know he never said the c word
now there's no there's no term for a
white guy that would
like is there any term that they will
tell you redneck if somebody called me
that stuff makes me
mad really ready someone called me a
hockey i'd laugh my ass off punk i don't
care redneck gets me some time
yeah it depends but sometimes it gets me
from the south maybe
well i think it's also it just depends
on if somebody says it like in a meet if
they say it in a mean way
so if i came to the studio too i was
like what's up redneck come on dog
if you called me redneck er yes oh if i
thought it
threw the er on it he said rednecka
what's up rednecker
i probably wouldn't mind that much that
sounds pretty cool so redneck can offend
you nick anything
um i guess like like you said it's all
about intent if someone's like
orphan someone said i should have said
that man oh my god and it doesn't really
have any
glass on it makes me feel like i'm not
in here
uh white trash i guess have you said
that with a lot of vitriol because i'm
from wisconsin like hickey
what about cracker cracker bother you no
no christian
any word i can call you offend you what
is there any word i can
reference to you that would offend you
probably adult uh no none that offend me
but there are like a couple for like
italian americans like
uh [ __ ] uh
wet ass [ __ ] guinea why would somebody
call you that
why would somebody think you have wet
ass [ __ ] we
yeah that's uh that's what the term
means now for the kids
and none of them really offend me
because i'm not
a baby like whatever happened to the uh
saying sticks and stones may break my
bones but words will never hurt
social media social media took that yeah
social media because if one person says
you're like whatever but
on social media we have 9 000 people
saying it hurt your feelings
let's see what this guy has to say are
you asleep
i haven't had caffeine for 20 days right
now why why do you do this to yourself
because i don't
i just may i feel like it like
exacerbates pain in my neck
when i have it weird like inflammation
yeah so i'm trying to go like
maybe 22 or 24
days yeah i think i do feel better i
can't barely stay awake but i feel the
decent
did the did the first days you have like
vicious with withdrawals
i don't know if i did man i'm always
having withdrawals i feel like from this
everything
that makes sense so people are like are
you quitting smoking like i [ __ ] quit
14 months ago
i tried i tried getting off coffee and i
lasted eight hours
i was in a on a fetal position shaking
on the ground really yeah i drink too
much coffee
oh i'll never stop but that's also your
mating call dude fetal positions shaking
on the ground
yeah yeah man see what this guy has to
say yeah here's a man right here hey
steven from minnesota man
i got a debate club forgot this question
that's okay
when you guys are chefing up on the
stove
use the teflon dawn or that
god damn cast iron hitter oh
that's what i use because you can pick
that thing up i made that
use it as a self-defense weapon that was
yours flip you some flapjacks in the
morning for the kids
and then cook up anything on the stove
you need man so amen
i want to know what you all think about
that man looking to see theo on
uh in minneapolis man that'd be the
great so gang gang buzz buzz man
and gang buzz buzz baby we'll see you
there that's from kow steaks right there
that beautiful meat they sent me that
little rib eye doggie grilling me up a
little steak meat right here son
yeah look at that i think there's some
uh front strap or something i don't know
what that is baby damn
loin huh oh yeah look at the nut in
there i see it
yeah that marble sauce there that's nut
yeah that looks nice man
oh and then people sent me these things
they were so mean yeah everybody was
talking [ __ ] about his pan
what was wrong with the pan it's it's
teflon they want me to get one of those
big cast irons
it sounds like you've donated up to the
good fight foundation japan is trash
might as well fry that [ __ ] on the
street
people were not doing well man people
were
get that grandma's pan out of here
grandma's ass pen
yeah yeah cast iron man
yeah people went at me man but i enjoyed
that meat man only grill [ __ ] man like a
like a real man you do yeah
pan steaks for [ __ ] is it is that
what i made um
that's a [ __ ] thing damn i don't even
know that
well you never told me anything i i
didn't see it man
dang well that's what i've been eating
what do you guys been eating over there
chin
i eat meat all day and there you go
right there
are you guys fasting because of what
happened to that comedian
no not fascinating i would do that
actually you would fast if a community
went after
no i would fast and honor that kid for a
day
if that if if that was a white guy or
should i say a redneck
no yeah maybe i wouldn't i wouldn't fast
you'd fast if he didn't
repost it right since he reposted you
don't want to fast from anymore right
i'm just trying to put myself in a
position where if that happened to me
the other problem is that club the
vulcan gas company i've played there
it's not a standard comedy club it's a
night club nightclub uh like
music venue so there's no signs i say no
filming no no recording so
that's kind of the wild west there you
know it's a great venue
but it's not you like if you if he if
they did that improv he probably would
have got shut down
but you know what actually there was a
girl that's why kevin hart
takes everybody's phones so joe rogan
for a long time
there was a girl comedian one time who
was saying like [ __ ] all these white
people on stage right and it was a white
girl
it was a black girl and that [ __ ] made
me really really mad
you know so i do remember being upset
about that
um it's bad timing for tony too right
because all the asian hate stuff like
couldn't get worse
right but again it's not meant to be
broadcasted to the masses
right i don't wish that i would have
recorded that girl set i wish that in
the club
you said something at that moment i
would have said something you're too big
of a [ __ ]
uh no i just felt like you got in your
car and thought about it it wasn't worth
like
it just wasn't worth arguing with her
she wasn't even funny
yeah so it just wasn't working have you
ever seen her again i've seen her again
everywhere she goes she ruins everything
ooh i bet i could guess who this is
i'm not going to yeah she's like mixed
yep i know exactly who you're talking
but um
she's hot though well yeah mo
doc that's right this program is brought
to you by the hulu original series
modoc i can't wait to watch this one
have you guys heard about modoc
modok is this insane and hilarious new
hulu original
from marvel patton oswalt stars as the
voice of the super villain modoc
the mental organism design only for
killing
m-o-d okay that's a mouthful modoc has
long pursued his dream
of one day taking over the world but
after years of setbacks which we can all
relate to
and failures which i can relate to
fighting in the earth's mightiest heroes
modoc has run his evil organization aim
into the ground
while also dealing with his crumbling
marriage and family life modoc is about
to confront his greatest challenge yet
marvel's modoc
all episodes now streaming only
on hulu today's episode is brought to
you by unleashed
with the dingo and danny a new podcast
fueled by monster energy
unleashed gets up close and personal
with the best in alternative action and
motor sports
get ready for untold stories career
defining moments and inside secrets from
the world's best
athletes and trailblazers you want that
don't miss out on the action new
episodes drop every
two weeks on mondays listen wherever you
get your podcasts
or watch on monster energy's youtube
unleashed with danny and the dingo
fueled by monster energy
i got tickets going on sale right now
and they're at theovonne.com
tour and that st louis cincinnati
charlotte durham chattanooga knoxville
wilmington wilkes-barre
and some other places charleston
richmond albany
buffalo columbus and minneapolis but i'm
excited man so go check it out
theovon.com
tour and thank you guys as always for
your support let's see what this guy has
to say it's pretty intense topic
you can't hear once you hear hot dude
once you have to hear hot it can get a
little aggravated yeah
yo king in this thing it's your boy
zachariah from asheville north carolina
nice originally from college in
louisiana like your boy theo
vanessa is god he's out of covington
primates escape
during my [ __ ] tenure down there
let's go up here when i was about 12.
but um y'all should come visit asheville
north carolina sometimes it's pretty
cool
anyways debating creationism
yeah i feel like [ __ ] or
evolution that joe rogan [ __ ] primate
split
what y'all think let me know gang gang
buzz buzz
were you landing on this beezy wait give
it to what's he asking
is threading your eyebrows what
creationism versus
evolution so basically religion versus
evolution
go with evolution
and evolution is on this planet
came from primates i think some of us we
could have involved from primates and so
i think we i think we evolved from
monkeys that god created
yep i agree so they both yeah so i think
kind of both really
but i don't know man there's sometimes i
feel like a monkey and there's a lot of
times where i don't
you know and also you know i've done
comedy about this before that there's
not that middle
where's the middle monkeys at you know
where's that middle ground
between us and monkeys you don't meet a
guy yeah you will you start
doing the road more you're gonna see
some of those people out there yeah you
might be right i've been called the
geico caveman more times than i can
count
really maybe i'm the middle yeah oh i
think i said then i've stopped saying it
i'm sure you get it everywhere it's fine
yeah i think uh you know it's funny man
i was thinking about this yesterday
while i was driving i like to think that
we
there's some greater plan for us or that
we have some connection to some like
divinity or something bigger
something bigger yeah yeah because
here's the thing
you don't see number they kind of jump
from like number three to number five
you know i'm saying you're missing a
couple of players on the team there you
think i don't think so that's a pretty
[ __ ] solid starting seven this is me
right here
that's a solid starting seven and from
five to five to six makes sense and six
to seven makes sense
but dawg you telling me from three
to four it is weird it is weird you're
just look you've never met number four
look at number four no no four straight
chimp i've ever seen number four is
chimpanzee
but no it's not though look at his legs
you've never seen a chimpanzee
just wandering around looking for his
wallet you know what i'm saying like
that's not the same thing bro four to
five's tough number
four could almost go into a t and buy
something for sure
okay i did i finally did or my sister
did 23 of me
and i got back i'm 1.2 congolese
congolese baby i'm going to start saying
the n word
well take it easy yeah don't say it
please don't do it in here don't say it
anymore he's doing on your other
seven podcast network this guy's got a
relationship advice too
um chin are you upset that we asked you
about that about the peter danger no why
i just didn't know if you were not chin
the other day about it i wanted to feel
them out here
get a real asians perspective yeah i
just tried cause i'm trying to figure
out exactly where i was
around comedy so jim was like yeah they
shouldn't have filmed it but it's a bad
joke
yeah but his first response was they
shouldn't have filmed it if you're not
around comedy like
i don't get i don't get it you're saying
something offensive why wouldn't they
post this
yeah because that's not there's rules to
this game can't post that [ __ ] man
dude i was on a so when jeff scott over
about a comedy store and he was a
you know famed fellow of it and he had
hiv and everything
and he died right the pianist and so
when he died
uh they had a call a group
call it was a mortuary call call
for people who wanted to be at his
funeral service
so there's like 90 people on this call
right
every now and then stories would get
kind of sentimental right when that
would happen
there's a comedian um and he would yell
out things like he was a homosexual
he had eggs right and i will tell you
this there were 94 people on this call
some of his family and friends everybody
on there
laughed right died laughing but now put
that in an article
so you know they're doing this
sentimental thing this communion kept
yelling out he had aids he's
hiv-positive that dude gets canceled
right and it was a
he did only did it at certain times and
everybody knew the timing was good and
also
knew the time was good and knew that
this that they'd had a relationship
they'd work together
yeah they're boys they were boys and
they worked together for
dozens of years so there was a so you
got the full context right
so yeah i just think there's a little
bit of that of just always when you do
something like that you take stuff out
of context
i did yeah it just maybe wasn't that
funny i don't know what the context was
i don't know if they'd been doing that
all week together if that was the first
time that it happened
i know they've performed together before
because someone sent me a text that
showed his previous tweets from weeks
prior
being like so thankful for tony
hinchkoff bringing me to san antonio and
other spots so
yeah yeah i don't know i'm just kind of
i'm just kind of thinking about it like
but remember this happened louis ck not
to this magnitude where they filmed it
but
he did when he came back from you know
all his accusations
jacking off in the corner on plants and
whatever he did and remember he came
back he was doing sets
and people from the the media
would watch his show and then write it
and then post it
in in the articles like oh he's talking
about the shootings at sandy hook and
all this stuff
and then we read the context you're like
jesus christ listen lucy k is one of the
best there is
yeah it's like out of context it looks
horrible yeah same with tony hinchcliffe
like
out of context yeah it's hard to defend
him but it's also a comedy show man
there shouldn't be cameras yeah and you
and it's just like
he's one of the comics where it's a
that's his thing it's like yeah a lot of
it's insulting
like lowbrow kind of stuff a lot of
people actually but then also he's one
of the quickest witted
joke writers he wrote right for the rose
he's wrote for years
years for the roast it's his thing yeah
i don't know i mean it's just a rough
situ i just feel like i guess i feel i
don't know
i just wish that it had it felt like it
was shared for clout that's why i didn't
like with the hashtag
but then also a younger generation
people's feelings are different
different people that's a lot more
feelings it's a different arena but
again tony hinchcliffe's lane of humor
is not for everybody so when these young
people if you're offended by that
don't buy a ticket to a show yeah it's
that easy don't buy the ticket of the
show
if you don't like comic book movies
don't buy a [ __ ] movie theater
if you do don't record it and then post
and talk [ __ ] about it
it's not for you but you're just looking
for a reason to be upset
yeah i guess yeah i just wonder what
that guy's i wish i knew the kid better
too so i know what his mo
if there was any mode you know like just
what some of his motive was even if it
was just like i feel like i need to
speak up for my people you know
he was raised in a real indigenous type
but to your point again we don't know
maybe did he say something to tony like
do quit doing that man
i've had friends and family here and
they're offended please stop doing that
right into tony double down on that we
don't know
and some of this goes back to that black
guy or whoever punched the asian guy
you know it's like some of that energy's
still in the air oh dude
the asian hate right now is you know
it's all over the media so this but it's
not that
it adds to it yeah this just adds to it
now that's another thing
if it wasn't asian hate month then i
don't know if they would even have it
you know
it's a form of gaslighting that asian
hate you know just
this is the problem you know they're
just i mean
but you said you haven't noticed that in
your community aren't you no but i do
have
i have one friend that was like you
don't speak up about it or whatever and
then he gave me this article about this
girl
that found urine in a cup on her car
and then it said like fu [ __ ] everybody
and i'm like how real is this right so
she empties the bottle
sits in her car and takes pictures of it
and puts it on instagram okay so
everyone's like
come on you're faking this [ __ ] so
there's got to be some fake [ __ ] out
there too
right that could also be a guy trying to
help her out right i could be a guy
helping out maybe she was trying to pass
the drug test he was clean
who's going to do that he's going to put
urinate in a cup and then write all this
hateful stuff on a girl's car
countless homeless people would no
basically the homeless no no anthem no
it's not though homeless aren't gonna
just leave a cup because then you can
get five cents for that they're just
going to piss on the coke
no i found a homeless guy in my truck
one time in louisiana slept in there
overnight because i left the doors
unlocked sorry about that
i want to say man look i did a set last
night and half the audience was
uh indian asian mexican man and half of
them were there to see me it felt like
and i just want to say that like
i don't feel like we have any hatred
towards anybody from this on this show
never can me look at the people i roll
with yeah
we roll with [ __ ] rats and bees man
i'm the only white guy in my crew
you are yeah christian well
yeah christian's part of the crew now
and christian have you ever gotten an
issue with any asians or not be honest
with us i know you grew up in an area
where there's a lot of uh
phil uh not filipinos do you take
adderall and go out looking for hate
crimes
uh no i actually didn't really have that
many issues with asians like i i don't
have issues with asians at all
honestly okay uh there's actually
surprising
a lot of asians where i'm from because
they go all go to this ivy league school
near us
and you can say the next i mean i love
them i love their food i love everything
about them
yeah i don't know why you'd have any
problems if anything i'm angry that
asian women don't like me
me too i'm just not their type no i'm
too big well you're married
but also leave them for me
you know when sometimes you're right
dude on this you're right
you say a lot of [ __ ] but when
you're right you're right dude
a lot of legit [ __ ] but you i even
though i'm taking you can still
like send a note every now and then send
me a couple
piss yeah man please do something for me
yeah do a nasty note bro that could be a
vietnamese valentine dude a cup of pits
on your car
who even knows bro yeah dude i was in
vietnam one time
i bought a bird i think i've told this
story 20 times right i went to a market
outdoor market and they're killing
people they're killing pigs
or they're killing pigs like anything
you want they kill it fresh right i mean
right there it's in a cage
you could literally think it's a pet
store if you're a kid and wake and have
a rude awakening
so i bought a dove in there i bought
about a dollar and 20 cent dove in there
right deal so i'm thinking i'm i'm yeah
it wasn't good i'm setting this thing
free i'm changing the game here right
i walk out of the market and literally
go like this to let it free right right
i caught that [ __ ]
there were two there was like kind of
this little walkway and these little
parks that were like just up off the
ground like little
grassy knolls kind of a vietnamese dude
as it's taking off
jumped off of the edge of that thing
caught the bird
landed broke its neck put it on his
shoulder like this
and walked off right in front of him i
mean
dude that's basically an alley-oop
that's what you do yeah that's a vietnam
alley ooh where i come from man oh dude
yeah it really is did you see
this guys yeah let's see what this guy
is what this lonely man has to say
that's basically brendan dassey's dad
what's up king of the sting hey brendan
atheia hey culture corner uh
this is steve from raleigh north
carolina
resident 26 year old who looks like he's
45.
oh no i got a question for relationship
advice
or what maybe lack of relationship
advice
uh i'm pretty thick 350.
whoa pretty fat to be honest
haven't been in a while it's not funny
brendan now do i
chase those larger women
no hefty honeys no hefty honey maybe try
to give them a little bit of love i'm
not attracted to that that's not my kind
of thing but i'm wondering it's been a
while maybe just to get back on the
horse
you chase those kind of women or do i
wait do i work my ass off i'm
uh 25 you know 25 or so pounds down good
for you
but just continue to work my ass off and
hold it hold it for a little bit so uh
let me know your thoughts
love you guys uh you know gang gang buzz
buzz
i would i would hold it man i would hold
it don't grab some big heifers dude have
a little pride bubba
two two three fifty you know you gotta
be three something to do something in
that bedroom with him man
let's just hold off keep losing the
weight man and find your real honey
that's quality
yeah quality over quantity yeah i think
that's a good
statement is quality over quantity
because
i can't even eat it i can't even have i
can barely masturbate if i've had too
much dessert
so i can't even imagine i think having
that much extra weight you know my body
i've just never had it
but i think if you want to feel better
you know i have kind of like a lot of
weight in my butt actually and so
yeah i'll get well documented yeah and
i'll get nervous sometimes and walk out
of the room backwards if i'm with a
woman
like that you don't want to see that big
floppy ass
i really have like a substitute
teacher's ass yeah you know you're that
sloppy joe ass
will you calm down okay i'm right here
dude
and it's asian awareness it's asian
awareness month
but here's what i'm saying first of all
yeah that was a mogul do you know what
that word yeah
definitely that was a black diamond
right there
look man i think you're gonna be fine
dude and here's a great way for you to
meet women
substitute teach oh yes the other
teachers they're hanging out you're the
new guy
that's a great idea but also in a small
town you get to meet people that
eventually will be old enough for you to
date and you can
date them later right is that bad
uh some would say that's grooming
and that's not what i'm saying dude what
i'm saying is my name
is tony hendrick okay
that is what i'm saying today and i
support my own message have you ever
have you ever been with a big girl
dude i remember one of my famous
substitute teachers man he told us that
uh kombucha mushrooms are gonna be like
the biggest thing in the world
and he would bring in this big jug this
big huge pickle jar filled with kombucha
mushrooms
making his own tea he'd be at the front
of the room just ladling it
into his mouth he would tell us it gives
us all these sexual powers and
he had no hair he was [ __ ] out sounds
like he was trying to [ __ ]
he was broke get all the kids all high
oh dude he'd let you come up and you
just ladle something right on your
[ __ ] gullet bro
who else is sick of the catcher in the
right i want your kids to get on these
feet man
um but i think man i think sometimes
having women as a goal can be kind of
nice if you just say look i'm gonna
stick with my fitness thing for a while
and focus on this
and then i'm gonna go out there and date
because if you date now and then things
don't work out it might make you feel
depressed some if there's like some let
downs and then you might attach that
to your working out which might not be
helpful for you but again quantity over
uh quality over quantity but then also
there's a lot of
the like honeys out there who like
bigger dudes
maybe it's you're just in a small town
man they don't like the big boys but
you get out of that little town there
some some people like them big boys now
oh yeah it's a thick boy summer i think
he could find a big girl and just start
popping
out some offensive linemen get himself a
whole team eat some offensive tackles or
some [ __ ] yeah another thing
is yeah um yeah future breeding well
tony bacelli's out there
this guy's got one
brendan theo got a debate club for you
do you put your
chips on your sandwich or do you put
them on the side
i always go for on the sandwich gotta
get that extra crunch
gang gang buzz buzz how about both
because i'm a god damn
free citizen really yeah i do both man
i'll put them in the sandwich and on the
side
oh crunch crunch praise crunch raise
um i will do
in the beginning i won't do it if i have
what i like is when i was younger we had
two halves of sandwich
so one half i would do natural you know
just get the elements of the sandwich
and then the second half i would maybe
put some chips doll it up put a sauce on
it
you know do something nasty honey dijon
yeah dude do whatever i want you know
god i love chips man i had them in
forever really oh i love them why
haven't you been having them
you know trying to get in shape really
for what ah
life oh dang
let's see what this guy has to say
bernie shaw he's got that shirt everyone
theo brendan dallas culture corners cody
nolan out here in
fort worth texas out here trying to make
my dog shitbox to look a little bit
better
she over here watching me chilling got a
little debate club for y'all
doing your yard with your shirt on or
off don't remember if we had this before
but let me know what you think
personally i can't do my front yard with
my shirt off i got the
crew of finding bigfoot out here looking
for me but in my backyard i can get away
with it
brendan i think you can have your wife's
cousins out there working on the url for
you correct so you have your shirt off
standing there letting everyone know you
were in charge yep theo
i can see you out there some scissors my
man gang
buzz buzz yeah i'll have them workers
working too man gang gang trim trim baby
they go big daddy this short enough i go
nope keep going
yeah so i tell them every time every
time now when i was a kid i started a
lawn mowing business made my own
business cards
i wouldn't say started a long moment is
you cut your yard no man i started lawn
mowing business that was my job and then
i created business cards
i put george jetson on there mowing a
lawn because i could draw a little bit
put my cell phone on there 20 bucks
it was a beast did you do any yards i
had way too much business i was
it was all i did as a kid and i dude i
was
purple i was so tense yeah and then
housewives watching me with my shirt off
all sweaty getting that lawn right you
want some iced tea
come in get some tea maybe some tits
every now and then oh really yeah
damn young kid with adults hitting on
you oh yeah
oh yeah men's and women's i remember we
went over this fella big
langenstein's house one time and he
ended up being a pedophile
but uh yeah and he was pedophile when we
met him too but he also ended up being
one
but he um he
one time we're over his house all high
and some men came over there and they
were all gay
and what happened dog nothing nothing
nothing nothing yeah
man i'll never forget these things could
smell them pedophiles i just
know i was like am i like i do i just
think everybody's real gay and creepy in
here because i'm high
or did you think you were in play
basketball because everybody they were
perverted men that's what i'm talking
about these were older men that were
perverted gay for children how could you
tell
huh how could you tell you could just
tell did they say stuff to you
um yeah one of them like uh
my buddy was putting uh was going to get
some uh
sour cream out of the refrigerator and
um
or i was going to get something he and
he goes hey man
can i have some of that sour cream and i
just yelled back i was like no you you
could have some of this sweet cream you
know talking about seed
yeah and uh that's a bad place to make
that joke and then one of the old mingos
can i have some
well dude and that's when the whole
scenario just didn't matter that's on
you though
180 people you were real cause i was a
child well you're a cocktails kid that's
what i'm
doing oh man yeah shaking your ass
friends we're getting canceled for this
dude
uh we'll close it out with uh cats in
the wild someone found theo at a fish
concert back in the day
it's so hard look at his mom right
behind him
being like this is what he [ __ ] wants
for his birthday mom can't wait to get
the [ __ ] out of there
we get a better shot
that kid is lit
oh my god
oh yeah let's go
that boy's on the next is seeing some
fish oh yeah they should just let those
people have sex man
fish melts newbies tell me that's not
steel god a young theo look at that head
shot doug
yeah dude where'd you how old were you
when did that headshot
probably 13 14. i always had that nose
though huh
yeah baby the nose stays with it nose
first baby
yeah that's me right there dude
yeah yeah that's funny just some good
old boys
yeah you were at the wrong show yeah
dude i remember one time being so high
at a uh
at some concert i don't know it's
probably 311 or something like that
and i walked back to the back i couldn't
see right i thought it turned into a
raccoon right because i was on some kind
of drug
and i felt on some man and it was a
[ __ ]
cop bro i felt his badge in his
gun stop like son what the [ __ ] are you
doing he said get off me i said where's
the water fountain
you thought you were a raccoon because
it's that way i thought it was a raccoon
dude
and i'd seen raccoons drink out of water
fountains before because the buttons
easy to press for their hands
yeah they have real hands though yeah
that's crazy huh now maybe that's that
middle element you do
if you're talking about evolution and
yeah movie came from the coons on the
raccoon
and creation because yeah i just feel
like it because when you look at all the
animals
think about all the animals right and
then you look at humans
we're such an outlier really kind of
we're pretty
we're pretty closely related to those
gorillas and chimpanzees no
no they're staying in one little area
they're chilling they're not doing that
they're not all meeting up and doing
their business they are then they have
tribes and if a male comes that tribe
they kill them
but they're not doing a business or
anything well that's why we came about
we evolved man start businesses start
podcasting but then why don't
why haven't other why isn't a duck why
isn't somebody shown up
with water going off their back and a
beak and they're
doing a business because they didn't
evolve man but why that doesn't make any
sense
why not yeah they're stuck in time
that's crazy well no because they're
stupid they don't have the brain power
like the chimpanzees but
but they're smarter no dude yeah they're
way smarter
they're smarter but to that point though
to defend you like crows are smart as
[ __ ] dudes or
so are octopus or dolphins whales
yeah whales communicating [ __ ] like you
think one of these days
in maine a whale boy would just kind of
walk on out
yeah like aquaman maybe yeah like i'm
here hey finally you know
like there would be that one turn of the
wave yeah that would spark the deal
so that's what i'm just like that's why
it feels to me like there's got to be
some bigger plan here
i hope so okay okay
and god's going to watch this and judge
the [ __ ] out of us well god knows i love
him dude god is my girlfriend
yeah you didn't even say it whatever
helps you man you're afraid to say it
whatever keep you sober dude if god's
your girlfriend
whatever that therapist is telling you
dog that should be it'd be a good shirt
you think god is my girlfriend i don't
think so it's pretty offensive
how do you think those people that love
the lord it just means god loves you
dude no matter what
how about god's my boyfriend would that
offend people i don't know
i don't think it would do it make it
make that in that ass mold
ah i can't believe stevie's doing that
yeah i mean it just it's so much tougher
to think about him
safely now knowing he's just delving
into that cultural appropriation well
i'll tell you what bothers me is nick
said he's 50.
now i look at him deaf probably 45 i
think we probably hit it closer with 25
46. i texted him he hasn't got back
god he doesn't look that he's probably
sleeping or he's probably nothing in
that
box one of those two oh oh he's at
orizata in and out
he's probably whipping up a batch of bum
choy
is that it nick that's it dope tonight
when this airs i'm in uh
houston texas houston improv thursday
friday saturday
that's at the houston improv and then
the following month
june i forget uh early june i'm in
oklahoma city
brickstown comedy club in oklahoma
oklahoma city
but uh houston this week see you
thursday friday saturday
that's tonight y'all come on out
and uh i got tickets you can get them at
theovon.com
tour and we just added another show in
st louis
and we got cincinnati charlotte uh
durham
i think we got a late show there now and
um
uh columbus we're gonna put up a late
show
so theovon.com tour chattanooga
knoxville wilmington
wilkes-barre minneapolis charleston
richmond
some other places uh thank you guys for
joining us back on the road
gang gang buzz buzz brennan and theo
fighter and weight i got to go in and go
hard in the paint
i do not think i am in flow black rifle
coffee i'm ready to go
i need a sponsor i am a monster about to
open up with this at my concerts flow is
contagious browser outrageous thicker
than girls that are instagram famous
damn
hungry like i'm fresh off keto seeing
red like andrew santino
every song i hit like the great bambino
brendan ate the queso and the quesoritos
but
everything's gonna be fine hate on me i
theo looking do not type of dude they
got a pack of matches in his pockets at
all times
they sliding into my dms a couple of you
tribal couldn't beat them
quit playing like nintendo ds you don't
want to smoke like joey diaz
meaning y'all edible just got my
eyebrows threaded and i'm feeling
incredible
brandon son hit me up he said it's too
loud in the club can you pick me up
on a string
you